was ist da bloß in den Kanzlerkandidaten
der Union Gefahren
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
kontrolliert im Katastrophengebiet wo
zahlreiche Menschen tot geborgen wurden
wo unzählige noch vermisst werden wo
Dörfer weggerissen und die Infrastruktur
niedergewälzt worden ist
Steinmeier appelliert und bewundert den
Gemeinsinn trifft den richtigen Ton und
hinter ihm Albert Armin Laschet NRW
regierungsschef und Kanzlerkandidat als
sei er im Karneval und nicht in der
Todeszone der Flut es gibt eigentlich
gar nicht also mitten im Leid lacht
Armin Laschet ist eigentlich völlig egal
warum und worüber es ist eine unsägliche
Situation er benimmt sich nach allen
Regeln des Anstands vollkommen daneben
frankenwalter Steinmeier spricht zur
Nation eine Pressekonferenz mit dem
Bundespräsidenten ist ja eine Ansprache
die eine Tonlage hat die dem Ereignis
dem schrecklichen Ereignis des wir jetzt
alle das Leben Rechnung trägt und und
sozusagen Stimme verleiht und dann steht
im Hintergrund eine Gruppe von
pflegehaften Jungs die da irgendwie über
irgendwas vorzeln der eine ist der
Landrat der andere ist Armin Laschet der
Kanzlerkandidat und was ja schwerend
hinzukommt der Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen es geht also um das
Leid im Land aber es geht auch eben um
das Leiden sein Land er ist auch der
Mann der auch bei dieser Pressekonferenz
geredet hat und der seinem ganzen
Mitgefühl Ausdruck verliehen hat eins
kann ja nicht stimmen entweder das
Mitgefühl
oder das Lachen es passt jedenfalls
nicht zusammen wenn jemand mitfühlt
ehrlich mitfühlt wenn jemand wirklich
berührt ist wenn jemand die Situation
mitnimmt und das ist schon das was Armin
Laschet auch vorgegeben hat dann kann
man nicht wenige Minuten später in einer
solch
ausgelassenen Stimmung sein